Speaker 1: All right, this is a super interesting
story and a very different sort of military
related story than what many of us have become
accustomed to.
Yesterday, the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff, Gen. Mark Milley, was asked questions
by Republican Congressman Matt Gates about
the U.S. military examining critical race
theory.
Now, the term examining is really the appropriate
term.
Understanding Marxian economics doesn't make
you a Marxist and much the same way.
Examining critical race theory doesn't make
you someone who guides their philosophy or
runs the military on the basis of critical
race theory.
Although you may learn something that's relevant
or furthers your understanding, or maybe not.
But the point is simply understanding something,
examining it, learning about it doesn't actually
dictate your political philosophy.
And Matt Gates and others were just getting
after General Mark Milley, and he delivered
a concise and very astute explanation of why.
I mean, forget about just critical race theory.
There's a bigger issue here, which is the
right.
He doesn't say the right, but I've been pointing
out the right seems to fail to understand
the value of diverse knowledge for its own
sake rather than necessarily as a tool of
indoctrination.
So let's take a look at this clip.
This is General Mark Milley.
Super, super interesting stuff.
You'll see the camera if you're watching.
Go to Matt Gates at one point who's just sort
of shaking his head and he doesn't like it,
but he seems to know he's being schooled right
now.
Take a look at your chair.
Speaker 3: And thank you, gentlemen, for joining
us today.
I know my time is very precious, but I would
like to yield some of my time to General Milley
because I know that he had some comments that
he wanted to make when Representative Gaetz
was talking, as well as Mr. Wallace, about
a similar subject of the stand down and race
theory.
Would you like a minute or so to comment on
that?
Do you remember what we were?
Well, your line of questioning or thought
was there.
Speaker 2: Sure.
First of all, on the issue of critical race
theory, et cetera, all of you are much smarter
on whatever the theory is.
But I do think it's important actually, for
those of us in uniform to be open minded and
be widely read in the United States Military
Academy is a university and it is important
that we train and we understand and I want
to understand white rage and
Speaker 1: understand what he's pointing out
here.
Right.
The military trains for many contingencies
which never happen.
The military trains to understand circumstances
which may be good, bad or neutral or irrelevant,
because that's what you do.
You prepare, you learn, you understand.
Similarly, when you apply that and say, hey,
this is a university, you learn things in
university from math.
I mean, listen, have I used calculus to in
my work life?
No, but understanding it and going through
it has been extraordinarily valuable in terms
of now I understand how do we even learn math
at that level, which is not a particularly
high level.
But I'm not I'm not bragging, but I'm just
saying I'm not using it.
But it's still useful and much the same way
we should be seeing some of this these ideologies
and theories as well.
And that's an academic.
It's the most basic thing, right, about what
we what learning is on understanding.
Speaker 2: So what is it that cause thousands
of people to assault this building and try
to overturn the Constitution of the United
States of America?
What caused that?
Right.
I want to find that out.
I want to maintain an open mind here, and
I do want to analyze it.
It's important that we understand that because
our soldiers, sailors, airmen, Marines and
guardians, they come from the American people.
So it is important,
Speaker 1: by the way, Guardians, that's the
space for Trump thing.
You know, he has to say it.
It just it sounds so weird to hear it
Speaker 2: that the leaders now and in the
future do understand it.
I've read Mao Tse tung.
I've read I've read Karl Marx, I've read Lenin.
That doesn't make me a communist.
Speaker 1: This I mean, this is this is literally
the example I gave earlier in the show when
I was at the University of Massachusetts,
Amherst, one of the few then economics programs
which seriously taught what the class was.
Marxian economics with the with the late Stephen
Resnick, a coauthor, with Richard Wolfe in
many articles and even books, I believe it
didn't turn me into a Marxist, but I, I learned
what is the theory?
What is the genesis?
We we read Marx.
There was nothing dangerous going on.
It's called being informed.
And to hear Mark Milley say it, I have to
tell you, is fantastic.
Speaker 2: So what is wrong with understanding,
having some situational understanding about
the country for which we are here to defend,
and I personally find it offensive that we
are accusing the United States military general
officers or commission noncommissioned officers
of being, quote, rogue or something else,
because we're studying some theories that
are out there that was started at Harvard
Law School years ago and proposed that there
were laws in the United States, antebellum
laws prior to the civil war that led to a
power differential with African-Americans
that were three quarters of a by
Speaker 1: the way, the general knows much
more about all of these topics than Matt Gates,
but that probably doesn't come as a surprise
to anybody
Speaker 2: being when this country was formed
and then we had a civil war and Emancipation
Proclamation to change it.
And we brought it up to the Civil Rights Act
in 1964.
It took another hundred years to change that.
So look at I do want to know and I respect
your service and you and I both Green Berets.
But I want to know
Speaker 1: and by the way, it's not Matt Gates.
That's the Green Beret.
It's a different congressman who's there
Speaker 2: in the discipline and cohesion
of this military.
And I thank you for the opportunity to make
a comment on that.
Speaker 3: Thank you, General.
Speaker 1: So the general is completely right.
This is just called thinking.
This is called being a student of things.
This is called learning, understanding.
And it it makes absolute perfect sense that
this would be the perspective that an entity
like the military would take.
And it doesn't mean the military becomes woak
in the negative sense of of the term.
Now, just just to give you one reaction to
this, which is so funny after this last night,
Laura Ingraham on Fox News responded to this
and she said the reason this happened is because
of Democrats and the military industrial complex.
This she's like a trapeze artist.
She's a she's a contortionist.
I don't know how this is what she comes up
with, but let's listen to
Speaker 6: the active duty servicemen and
women about that, sir.
Now, somehow, I don't think General Milley
Speaker 1: would ever speak
Speaker 6: in this dismissive tone that he
took today to his Chinese counterparts, not
the way he spoke to Congressman Walts.
And question what I have a question for the
general.
Why would anyone risk his or her life for
a country that's systemically racist, one
that brutalizes minorities?
Speaker 1: This is what you call black and
white thinking.
Let's assume for a second that it wasn't just
that Mark Milley said, let's understand critical
race theory.
Imagine for a second that what Mark Milley
said was the military will now see critical
race theory as its guiding explanation and
system for understanding the country.
That's not what he said.
But imagine that Mark Milley went as far as
to say that.
Now, Laura Ingram says, Why would anyone be
in the military to defend a country that's
structurally racist?
Well, you wonder for those who subscribe to
critical race theory, presumably the next
step is how do we fix it?
And the same or similar motivation that would
lead someone if they joined the military for
the right reasons, which is, Wolf, I mean,
we can argue about whether the military is
used in this way.
But if you join not to go and kill people,
as some some do, but most don't, if you join
the military to try to make the country better
and if you believe critical race theory, you
would then want to change things to make the
country better.
In both cases, you're trying to make the country
better.
So hurt this black and white thinking of if
there is any systemic racism, then you wouldn't
even be in the military because you do not
want to defend a country that's systemically
racist.
It's just gutter black and white thinking.
Why would any country
Speaker 6: respect us or follow our lead if
that's who we are?
Those are some of the questions he should
probably think about before he touts the value
of teaching far left Marxists racist ideology
to our troops.
Speaker 1: And again, all he touted was we
want to understand what are the conversations
that are happening and what are the arguments
being made?
He never said let's become a woak critical
race theory military had he said that it would
be a different discussion.
Speaker 6: The fact is he has made his choice
and he's chosen to indulge the radical whims
of Democrats.
He'll do everything they tell him as long
as they keep the military industrial complex
flush with cash.
Speaker 1: And of course, that's just so silly,
given that, you know, the military industrial
complex is almost as big of an issue in terms
of blind support from Democrats than from
Republicans.
A little bit less.
You do hear some Democrats say we've got to
pare this down.
So for Laura Ingraham now to say, well, this
is all happening, he's taking a left perspective
because of Democrats funneling money into
the military industrial complex.
Republicans do far more of it.
So it makes no sense one way or the other.
And very interesting to see the statements
by General Mark Milley.